the Octavia is one of SCOTUS most
successful vehicle ranges and includes
the sporty RS models recently the
Octavia underwent a facelift and we're
going to test its mettle our tester
Michele Assenmacher says she's going to
test the Octavia RS at a driver safety
training center and she knows it'll be
fun that's largely thanks to the cars
turbo diesel engine which churns out 135
kilowatts of power it propels the new
Octavia RS to a top speed of 230
kilometers an hour and lets it go from
zero to 100 kilometers an hour in 7.9
seconds our test model sells for around
thirty three and a half thousand euros
in Germany the slalom course isn't the
only part of the test site that's
underwater and a flooded roundabout
Michele tries to get the Skoda Octavia
RS to stay on track that's harder than
it looks
okay he's fizzing okay I give up she
says and leaves this part to the
professionals this is what it looks like
with a trained Pro behind the wheel
[Music]
but Michelle says she's game to tackle
this slalom course the Octavius RS
models badged as VRS and some markets
have a 15 millimeter lower sports
suspension other features that add to
their sportiness include progressive
steering and optional dynamic chassis
control which lets drivers choose
between sport normal and comfort modes
from Skoda a box inside Michelle shows
us one of Skoda simply clever solutions
that can be found in the Octavia RS she
could open this water bottle with just
one hand
drink from it and close it again
while keeping one hand on the steering
wheel the new front looks masculine and
sporting o LED headlights set on either
side of the radiator grille make the car
appear wider the hood and the sharper
lines at the sides give the car an edge
your look
at the back the rear spoiler adds a
sporty accent
the abbreviation are S stands for racing
sport RS variants made their way into
the Skoda range in the year 2000 since
then these sporty models have won over
more and more fans Skoda Octavia RS has
proved particularly popular goddess
Michelle says she likes taking tight
curves with it best the car whines and
roars and it's just wow
it's a driving experience that you
simply have to experience for yourself
it's incredible because the car is so
good on curbs and that literally leaves
Michelle speechless
wow it's been it's been bookish and
Pescados gutter looks all in all the RS
is facelift has done more that just
spruce up its outer appearance changes
have been made inside as well the result
is a sporty sedan which has certainly
put a smile in our testers face
[Music]
as Oh Miata taco shell says she's had
lots of fun today she could leave the
traffic behind and push the Octavia RS
to its limits though she admits it was
more hurt limits that were being tested
because in the hands of the pros the car
can definitely do more
she thinks the Octavia RS is a good mix
it's fun as she found out today and good
for everyday use thanks to its simply
clever solutions oh I talked spur glad
to